advice do you give to your brothers you  know how I don't know how old they are  but are they in the dating age are they  having trouble in the dating Market no  they do really  they're all tall yeah they're tall  tall my older brother I'd say marry  marry your girlfriend because she's  great  um my other brother my oldest brother  that was given up for adoption he's  married my younger brother  um he's got a girlfriend I really like  her  um yeah I mean I would just say like try  to find the purest girl you can I mean  you can't you're never gonna really know  but I mean you can  like if you know her mutual friends you  can kind of see yeah you know